foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is James page here in Madrid at the
ftth council Europe event and I'm really
pleased to be joined by the oecd deputy
secretary General Uric vestigard Knutson
Ulrich thanks for coming over and
joining us a big discussion at the event
this week is about how we get affordable
Broadband to everybody uh everywhere
um perhaps you can tell us why that is
such an important goal it's because it's
important because our economies our
societies are increasingly becoming
digital and if we want everyone to take
part in that everyone to reap the
benefits of this digital transformation
we need connectivity that means we have
to tackle some of these divides that are
opening up a digital divides we call
them that is across genders across
geographies we need to get connectivity
also in rural areas if we do not give
everyone on board and everyone will not
benefit from the digital transformation
it's as simple as that and looking at it
perhaps in a larger perspective with uh
with globalization and to some extent
productivity uh at a bit of a Crossroads
we need the digital transformation in
order to develop our economies and
societies so to get everyone on board we
need connectivity we need high speed
Broadband connectivity and fiber is
probably our best bet okay so that
that's the goal um across Europe people
are achieving that at different rates uh
where do you think we are and how are we
going to to achieve that goal there is a
lot of uh progress and Spain the
contrary is one of the Front Runners in
in Europe other countries are picking up
at very very high growth rates when it
comes to to penetration through fiber so
so that's the good news but there's
still a long way to go and there's still
many rural areas that are not well
enough connected they may have some
connectivity but you know it's not only
just about being able to read your
newspaper on the net it's also about
teleworking it's about Taylor education
it's about telemedicine and so on and if
you're not able to have you know deep
quality sustainable connectivity you
cannot take part in all of these
activities of society that will be
digital in the future it's interesting
you you use that sort of terminology in
terms of connectivity because we are
here talking about ftth but obviously uh
what actually happens inside the home or
inside the building is is a topic that's
going to be talked about a lot here
that's that's just important as getting
the fiber there in the first place isn't
it it is it is indeed and you know
everyone uh in 23 has been talking about
generative IAH chat GPT and and so on
and that is another for some scary for
other you know promising development
that we need to regulate but also here
if we are to reap the benefits of that
we need the connectivity you know the
Internet of Things uh cloud
cloud computing and so on all of these
new new technologies we will not be able
to get everyone on board in the use of
them and in the to you know to benefit
from them if we don't have that
connectivity deep connectivity at
affordable rates as you said across the
board okay so um from your perspective
at the oecd what are you doing what can
you do to help that transformation that
you're so Keen to see well we need sound
regulatory Frame Works and there are
different opinions about how we best go
about this and and at this conference
we've already heard discussions about
whether the EU is about to you know
introduce some kind of Fair a shared
deal we have some uh some you know
ambivalent uh I would say experience
from that in in Korea but these are the
kinds of issues that we are analyzing at
the oecd we're offering our members and
non-members to come to the OCD to share
their best practices to see what is
working what are the best Politics the
best practices in order to get a fiber
to as many people as possible we all
agree on that goal but there can be
different paths to getting there that's
what we're discussing we want to help in
terms of uh you know advising with the
right policies but we also wanted to to
help in terms of getting the data right
if we cannot measure it it's very
difficult to improve it and I I have to
say if if everybody's coming together
this week with the same level of
commitment and passion that's clearly
coming across from from you at the
moment I'm sure I'm sure we'll get there
but for now thank you so much for taking
the time to come and have a quick chat
thank you a pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]